this extraordinary video shows a polar
bear begging for help she has a can of
condensed milk stuck on her tongue and
she seems to understand that humans
might be able to get it off but it's not
that easy and it looks painful
cue the professionals a rescue team
dispatched from moscow and flown almost
2 000 miles to dickson one of russia's
northernmost settlements
surgical kit anaesthetic and dart gun at
the ready moscow's chief vet a natural
in the arctic tundra
he takes a shot she runs a bit but not
for long she doesn't know it but things
are about to get a lot better
it looks gruesome but it takes just 10
minutes to remove the offending can her
tongue's sewn up and she's airlifted
back out to where she belongs away from
human habitation and its bittersweet
temptations
she doesn't look very well since first
of all she hasn't eaten for quite a long
time we don't even know exactly how long
she'd had that can on her tongue she's
also quite young which means she has her
mother somewhere they still live with
their mothers at this age so they can't
hunt well themselves
[Applause]
they leave her with 50 kilograms of fish
to wake up to a feast for a hungry bear
but as climate change melts the arctic
sea ice polar bears like her are coming
inland in search of food at risk to
themselves and to the towns they come
scavenging in
diana magnay sky news moscow